[Music]
watching a spacex booster land is a joy
and with the help of starlink spacex has
succeeded in making the event more
frequent than
ever before often launching multiple
rockets every single month
though launching falcon 9's has become
extremely common the speed of reusing
boosters hasn't really improved
much in 2020 spacex did set the record
for fastest turnaround
but that was only three days faster than
the space shuttle coming in at 51 days
evidently this is quite far off from
elon musk's vision that spacex would use
rockets in less than 24 hours by 2020
so why does it still take spacex so long
to reuse a booster
well in order to answer this question we
have to first take a look at where
exactly the time is spent in the first
place starting with of course the actual
refurbishment process
before any work on the booster actually
begins any excess fuel in the tanks will
be drained
and in some cases burned spacex has been
pretty quiet about how exactly the
refurbishment process
works so we'll have to rely on tidbits
we got here and there
hans koenigsmann the vice president of
spacex revealed that the majority of the
work
is the engine even though the booster is
designed to be fully reusable
spacex often replaces certain parts like
the turbine wheels
this isn't to say that these parts can't
be reused however
reusing them non-negotiably increases
the possibility of complications
during flight so spacex has stuck to a
good old role of better safe
than sorry aside from swapping parts in
the engine
spacex also has to clean the nine merlin
turbines which according to musk
is quite difficult moving on from the
engines
spacex boosters often show signs of
minor damage to the heat shield and aero
cover
from debris and the high temperatures
and pressures the booster experiences
koenigsmann assures us that this is
completely normal but this nonetheless
increases the refurbishment time
after this spacex inspects the fuel
tanks however
on occasion they have found some damage
caused by the thermal protection system
spacex has revealed that the entire
inspection slash processing stage
is usually completed within 30 days once
all the inspections
repairs and replacements are done spacex
moves on to the testing stage
in this stage spacex will go ahead and
complete many of the common rocket tests
like the stack fire test
again these tests aren't actually
required to have a successful flight
however this can prevent a more serious
disaster during the actual flight
so as you can see refurbishing a booster
and getting it ready for launch
generally takes several weeks and this
is where the bulk of the time between
launches
is spent fortunately though most of the
processes during refurbishment
is simply precautionary steps so as
falcon 9 continues to prove its
reliability
spacex will likely be able to cut down
on the inspections and replacements they
have to complete between flights
with minimal additional risk the
refurbishment process
isn't the only step between falcon 9
launches though another major hurdle
when it comes to reusing a booster
is the rest of the rocket after all
there is no purpose in just launching a
booster
into space spacex has worked on making
as many parts of the rocket reusable
as possible even including the fairings
but
there are still major parts that are
still not reusable specifically the
second stage of the rocket
spacex originally tried to give the
second stage of the rocket the ability
to land
just like the boosters however there are
a variety of problems in actually doing
this
for starters the second stage is
traveling over three times faster than
the first stage
and more importantly every kilogram of
heat shields and landing gear you add on
to the second stage
is one less kilogram of payload thus
spacex decided that instead of reducing
payload capacity it would actually just
be cheaper to build a new second stage
every single launch though this likely
makes more sense economically
this severely hinders spacex turnaround
time with boosters
even if you're able to turn around a
booster every 24 hours like elon musk
envisions
it's gonna be quite difficult for spacex
to pop out or ready to launch second
stage
every single day similarly spacex will
also need a payload every single day
for it actually makes sense to launch on
such a tight schedule
right now there aren't nearly enough
commercial customers or sterling
missions to make that a viable operation
so not only does the actual
refurbishment of the booster still take
many weeks
but you also have to take into
consideration the manufacturing and
testing time for all the other parts of
the rocket
as well anyways moving on from technical
challenges
we have logistical challenges on video
rocket boosters look nice and small and
easy to handle
in reality the falcon 9 booster is about
50 meters tall
or more than 11 stories tall as a result
transporting boosters is not easy by any
means
first of all the booster often lands in
the atlantic ocean 680 kilometers
away from the coast transporting this
back to land itself takes upwards of a
week
considering the fuel requirements of
crew dragon missions gto launches and
stalling missions
all of the boosters of these missions
have to land in the ocean
so spacex can't try 24-hour turnaround
with any of their most frequent missions
anyways after this giant is logged back
to land it is laid horizontally on a
massive 44 wheel trailer to transport it
to the refurbishment facility
on the bright side spacex doesn't have
to transport the booster
all the way back to hawthorne california
or mcgregor texas
as they have to do when manufacturing
and launching booster for the first time
so those are the most significant
obstacles when trying to reduce the time
between reusing boosters
but there are also several miscellaneous
obstacles as well
for each launch spacex needs to get
licensed from the fcc
faa licenses last a long time and cover
all the launches that take place within
that time frame
but fcc licenses have to be obtained
every single launch
as we all know dealing with the
government is not a fast process by any
means
and for some reason obtaining a simple
license from the fcc
often takes weeks something else to
consider is that rocket launches are
quite violent
so the original launch pad is often
slightly damaged and this requires a
couple of days of inspection
and repair even if all this is completed
swiftly
there's still one uncontrollable factor
which is weather
the temperature has to be above 40
degrees fahrenheit the wind can't be too
fast
there can't be any lightning and so on
and so forth
over the past couple of years spacex has
been trying their best to improve the
speed and efficiency of each of these
steps
for instance processing boosters
arriving at the port used to take a
couple of days itself
recently though spacex has been able to
cut this down to about one day
but we're still a very long way from
cutting down the entire process
to just one day at the end of the day
there are dozens of moving parts which
make a quick turnaround time
difficult and the truth is consistent 24
hour turnarounds are likely over a
decade away
here's the thing spacex can design their
rockets to be as reusably friendly
as possible but many of the factors
required for a fast turnaround
are out of their hands now this isn't to
say that it'll take spacex another
decade to reach a 24-hour turnaround
time
it's very possible that even within the
next few years spacex attempts to
complete a 24-hour turnaround
and succeeds but at that point this feat
will still not yet be a reliable
and consistent event in other words
spacex likely had to pull a lot of
strings to make this happen
they probably launched an extremely
light payload on their first launch
so that they can have the booster land
back at the launch site as opposed to a
drone chip
similarly they would likely skip several
tests and inspections which they would
never skip
during a crude mission thus the first
time spacex succeeds in this feat
it will likely be more of a stunt as
opposed to something spacex will employ
on a regular basis something else to
keep in mind is that there is literally
no practical reason for spacex to even
do this
at this point in time spacex has several
falcon 9 boosters
so even if they wanted to launch every
single day they only need to bring down
the turnaround time to just
one or two weeks to make this possible
considering this
the falcon 9 is very unlikely to evolve
into a daily launcher
as starship develops into a full-scale
rocket though many of these issues
may be eliminated starship is only a
one-stage rocket and is fully reusable
so we won't have to deal with
manufacturing parts between each launch
also it is expected that starship will
mostly be launching from
and landing on drone trips in the ocean
so that should significantly reduce
logistical issues
as well as bridge violations moreover
there's not very many people living
on the ocean so spacex will likely have
to meet less faa guidelines when
launching from the ocean
as opposed to launching from land
starship does pose other challenges
though
if starship doesn't return to land
between launches spacex will have to
figure out how to inspect and repair if
needed
at sea spacex will also have to figure
out how to refill starship regularly
at sea i'm sure the crazy people at
spacex have already thought of all of
this
and have a plan so i'm hopeful that we
do eventually get rapid
and maybe even instant reusability but
at this point
this is still like a decade if not
decades out
what do you guys think is the most
significant challenge in reusing a
booster
comment that down below also drop a like
if you guys thought this video explained
the various challenges well
and of course consider joining our
discord community to suggest future
video ideas
and consider subscribing to see more
questions largely answered but until
then
i'm hari and i'll see you guys on the
next one
[Music]